[Music]
okay everybody I'm so excited today
because I am joined by the one and only
Frank Grillo AKA Doc and Little Dixie
which is in theaters and on demand now
how you doing today Frank I'm good man
how are you I'm really good I'm so
excited to talk to you I absolutely love
this film excited for people to see it
um as we see in the trailer you get to
wield a freaking chainsaw at one point
having done so many action films is that
the type of stuff that like keeps it fun
for you is that like what makes you want
to sign up for something like this yeah
I mean well John Schwab you know him and
I are at this point I think we have our
own company uh with Jeremy Rosen I mean
we're we're a team but uh look I live in
this world of of you know lower budget
action thrillers in the genre world and
uh yeah anytime there's a chainsaw and
somebody's head I'm in man oh hell yeah
and that translates to the audience
because they see Frank Grillo chainsaw
I'm in so that that's great so I also
like in this film we can actually see
your tattoos in the film do most of your
recent Parts allow for this and is it a
pain when you have to cover them oh
that's a great question most because
they're not proprietary I got most of
them in Thailand and other parts of Asia
um I don't have a problem but sometimes
I do have to cover them uh because it's
just not part of the character and it's
a pain in the ass because they're all
kind of they're done tap tap and they're
black and it's not easy to cover these
things and uh so it's a pain in the ass
but I always try to work in the tattoos
yeah no that's smart that's cool I like
that yeah that that gets really for
people want to act with tattoos and yeah
um do you stay the same course like your
processing actor or do you try different
approaches on different projects like is
there like a book for Frank here brother
that's the first time anyone's asked me
that question I swear to that's a great
question yeah man because I you know I
listen to actors talk by the way there's
nothing more boring than listening to an
actor talk but you know I I kind of look
I know how to act I know I know how to
act right so I approach everything with
a little bit of a different Flair like
depending on how I feel and and uh you
know sometimes I fall flat on my face
but sometimes I make some great
discoveries and I think that's what it
should be about and and uh and this is
no different it's you know with Doc I
had to be really far more reserved and
quiet internal and I was almost even
though it's the lead of the movie the
movie's told through I almost felt like
I was the third lead behind Eric Dane
and Annabeth dish and I had to come from
out of the shadows and it was very
interesting I loved playing a guy
because my favorite actors like Charles
Bronson and and uh McQueen and you know
they like to take the dialogue out and
and this was a guy who didn't say much
and it was it was fantastic do you feel
like or did you have any knowledge that
was this role specifically written with
you in mind of Doc uh and what John
called me and said uh I got one I just
wrote one I finished uh it's it's I
wrote it with you this guy is you tell
me what you think and I said before he
even got off the phone I said well
here's first I'm doing it we're doing it
and I'll read it and get back to you and
I have to tell you with with John unlike
most other people uh this is also true
of Joe Carnahan uh I didn't make it made
many changes man like the script was
great the words are great I love saying
his words I don't need to invent
anything and that's just that's just a
relief yeah and that's that's cool you
do a great job with it in this one and
do you what do you want the audience to
be feeling when I watch a film like this
I want them to feel kind of uh screwed
up I want him to feel maybe that whether
they but they don't like it or like it I
want them to feel like uh you know they
were on a roller coaster and uh they
feel a little uncomfortable yeah and I
think they will so no worries there and
also what I love too about you is you
are a guy you train like intense stay
active you're healthy dude does this
mean the plan for you is to act forever
is that a part of this like are you are
you planning to go whole way you know
you know I'd like to think you know I
have some great friends in in guys like
Liam Neeson and Stallone uh who I've
become friends with over the years and
and uh Mel Gibson and and you know these
guys like you know Liam Neeson 70 years
old and he's still kicking ass the loan
75 he's having a Resurgence with Tulsa
Kings and and I'm like you know now
these guys were Superstars I'm I'm not
at that I'd never have been at that
level but if in my world people still
come to me and then and they're
interested I I don't see why I should
stop I mean I I still TR I'm as spit as
I was when I was 30. and uh uh I
recently stopped drinking about 41 days
ago and I have a whole new kind of
perspective on on on my life and my
health and uh I feel like I'm I'm I got
a whole kind of second uh Second Wind Ah
that's amazing to hear and yeah we're
never gonna get sick of Frank Grill we
want more and more so keep it keep it
coming man watch Frank kill it in Little
Dixie in theaters and on demand now
thank you so much for joining me I'll
talk to you in the future one day man
thanks brother I appreciate you